Dr. Peterson,
I'm really hoping you can share your thoughts on the day.
Just shooting.
Yeah.
Well,
what I would do is recommend the biblical lecture I did on Cain enabled,
I would say,
because I think that that's a good summary of the state of mind that somebody
has to be in in order to do what was done at Los Vegas.
So you have to be very,
very embittered by life in order to do that sort of thing.
And you have to be searching for revenge,
I would say.
And it's not,
you know,
you might think,
well,
it's only revenge on other people because you've developed a hatred for people.
But it's deeper than that.
It's not just hatred for people.
I would say it's hatred for being itself and,
and the desire to take revenge on being for the outrage of the tragedy and
suffering that's associated with being,
um,
and maybe the tragedy and suffering that's been part and parcel of your own
life.
And that makes you embittered.
And then past embittered becomes outraged and past outrage becomes well
homicidal or even genocidal.
And that's a terrible state of mind to begin.
It's a hellish state.
Um,
I believe that the best way to conceptualize the state of mind that someone has
to be at in order to do something like the Columbine shootings for example,
or what happened in Las Vegas is that you're really an hour.
You have to speak about it and religious languages.
You're really out for revenge against God,
for the outrage of creation.
That's what it looks like to me.
And that's a state of mind that's truly hellish and you could get there by
broody long enough.
Now it's also possible,
I mean this guy didn't have any previous history,
criminal history or anything like that and he's pretty old.
So you know,
there's also all also the possibility of some kind of neurological pathology
that that might be characteristic of him.
You know,
some degenerative neurological disease.
There was a kid years ago at the University of Texas in Austin who climbed up on
the tower there and shot a number of people with a high powered rifle and he had
a fast growing tumor on his hypothalamus and had reported like these being
overcome with extreme feelings of rage.
And so that's another possibility.
But I would say the,
uh,
embitterment hypothesis is the strongest one.
I would also say too,
I noticed the Steven Pinker tweeted this today,
is that one of the ways of controlling this sort of thing would be for the press
to agree,
not for there to be a blanket agreement,
not to publicize the name or any other identity markers of the people who do the
shooting.
Because there's also this really,
what would you call it?
Arrogance.
It's a kind of arrogance and pride last ditch,
arrogance and pride that that is associated with the fantasies that drive this
sort of behavior.
And the fantasy is like,
well,
after I do this,
everyone will sure know the who,
who the hell I was.
You know,
even though maybe I was ignored or unhappy when I was alive after I'm get,
everybody's going to know who I was and what idea,
you know,
so there's this underground desire for fame,
I guess it's notoriety,
but notoriety might be preferable to being ignored.
And so,
you know,
there's a lot of talk about gun control,
and that's understandable,
especially with regards to automatic rifles.
Um,
although I also understand why the people who are gun owners are afraid of,
of,
of allowing what they regarded as one of their fundamental rights to be
infringed upon.
But it would certainly be useful if we stopped giving people who do this sort of
thing,
not $100 million worth of free publicity and all the notoriety they can manage.
So,
you know,
that's another way of thinking about controlling it.
So.